anyone including
me, well, everyone here in the
countryside knows me
by
the name sebastián viera
herrera
because I was 67 years old, I was here with
my grandfather and my family since
I was little, they were whistling and
I put my fingers into  the
mouth can speak whatever it
had but I continue
and the goats also the tourist goats
a whistle and they understand when you want to
collect the cattle when you want them to
stop
if there was something new you also had to
go through the earthquake you would pass it on to the
next one  next to the other and that's how it went there it
took the best two hours and it was on
the other side of the island
without the whistle it would be like
skipping your speech
formerly it was mounted like a
shepherd whistling I was with a cattle
you with another the other with another was all
full of cattle
and they whistled at all the ranchers
and then that the field is
left alone and the people are marking
the century I forget and only the shepherds use it
to  dogs and
cattle
I think they are disappearing
more and more because in a town hosting
a place takes place in a century one to
another children now at school learn to
whistle they learn to understand it but
later they leave it because later
they will say to their jobs and in an office
your place is whistling
to be good camps
but to me it is that I like animals
and I like to herd and it is a
somewhat boring life for many people but for those
who grew up with that and they  like